it's interestingly it's not sort of five
which is the other number the team
suggested where are our multiples of
five excuse me the multiples of five
look really good five ten but then wait
a second
is no 15 then you go twenty twenty-five
you missed 30 35 because they're not
really the multiples of five are they
look carefully there's five then there's
actually it goes straight up to 25 the
next one after that would be 1 over 125
and then lastly you've got these weird
guys in here one of these guys here
what's going on these ones are the
strangers they are not powers of two
they're not powers of five either I
would just think back all the way to our
first lesson last term we were trying to
understand numbers right and I suggest
that you here you go go for it flip back
right I suggested to you that numbers
were a little bit like chemical
substances right chemical molecules and
if you can understand this structure a
little better you can understand the
numbers a little better right so the way
that we dug into the structure of a
number was we did what remember first
lesson we factorized and we didn't just
do any factorization we did the prime
factorization what's the prime
factorization of 10 what's the prime
factorization of 20
20 is 4 times 5 right so when you go
down one more step to get to the primes
you get 2 squared times 5 do agree prime
factorization and on my list that last
one 2 times 5 squared
isn't it now have a look do we have some
structure now we've got powers of 2
we've got powers of 5 and then lastly
these we'd guys powers of 2 and 5 mixed
together ok anything else as well as
poured out right at beginning multiples
of 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 cetera
they don't appear here why is that and
that's because I want you to look at
your hands can you look at your hands
just hold them up in front of you your
hands I'm not even joking your hands are
the reason for this pattern okay
how many hands do you have how many
hands do you have you have two and how
many fingers does each of your hips have
okay digit I don't know whatever yeah
I'm saying five okay this is not a
coincidence this is not a coincidence
right
five to lots of five we work with in
you're ready to make a M you can make a
heading finally at last I haven't been
telling you a heading compose it was a
spoiler we work within a system where
the base of our number system the base
of our number system is 10 why is the
base of our number system 10 and the
answer is you have 10 fingers that's it
if we had had 11 fingers if everyone
grew up was born with a left with a left
hand which had six fingers we would have
a base 11 system and it would be a
nightmare so that's
our base is 10 and so we call our number
systems they all know what's the neither
and I'm sister start on the D it has a
number 10 minute our number system is
called decimal right it's a decimal
number system now decimal base 10 is not
the only number system that's out there
I can think of at least three two of
which you interact with every single day
for example what time is it right now
that's not a rhetorical version what
time is it if I just missed it okay ah
five minutes ago five minutes ago what
time was it 759 time had certain base to
it right because five minutes later it's
not 764 so yeah 764 after five minutes
we say it nodes its 804 why do we say
804 why wasn't it 754 because the base
is 60 right and then the base goes down
if I said you know how many seconds
right you would never say are it's the
it's the 100th second of this minute
because the base is 60 right whatever
that number happens to be so time time
is base 60 at least in our system by the
way people have tried to change the
system of time to decimal but it's never
worked your computer's your phones
everything you have this electronic
doesn't work in a decimal and doesn't
work in basic things there are no our
base it works in it works in base to
which we call binary computers own base
to which is called binary
you can't write dubs very fast in binary
for example in base 10 right how many
digits do we have having different
digits do we had to make up a number we
have 10 0 K Pondy to here to this 0 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 those are the 10 digits
you've gotten you can build up every
number that you have but if you look
base 2 you do not have tended to choose
from you only have two digits to choose
from what are they 0 & 1
okay so numbers take forever to write in
this I'll show you an example in a
minute but before I do that I want to
tell you they're for their computers
also work in base 16 you never really
see this even though computers are doing
it because it's like decimal and then a
little war decimal plus 6 this is called
hexadecimal okay so there are all these
other number bases that are kind of
flying around your world that you don't
necessarily realize are there but you've
been working with them for a long time
okay